the logic and language video series
introduced logic as a way of
representing and analyzing sentences but
I skirted around questions of truth and
establishing good arguments I'd like to
take a stab at those topics those skills
in this video we've paid attention to
the structure of sentences and used
symbolic logic to represent that
structure on that front logic provides a
handy way to sort out and clarify our
statements please make sure to go
through those videos if you understand
that material you can see that the logic
of a statement like for example water is
a liquid may be represented as follows
for all X if X is water then X is a
liquid now that you have that kind of
grasp on logical statements you can
extend your logic to whole arguments
with multiple statements when I say
argument I'm afraid you may be hearing
heated exchange of words but I mean
instead a series of statements made in
support of an assertion together with
the assertion drawn from those
statements the supporting statements are
premises of the argument and the
assertion that follows from them is the
conclusion right now I want to convince
you that coffee is a food not a beverage
yeah you heard that right
I'll start with some sentences we both
accept coffee as a bean remember your
logic here I'm saying that for all X if
X is coffee then exits of being beans
are food so it follows that all coffees
of food I brought you to a conclusion
using to supporting premises but you
might think I'm pulling something over
on you here maybe you can't even put
your finger on it
hold your criticism for now and consider
the structure of my argument first is
the form of my argument any good well
what is its form
let's abstract the argument to a is B B
is C therefore a is C you'll find that
however you fill in this structure the
argument seems to work I bet you're even
smart enough to see why you really are
so let's move along if on the other hand
I tried to fill out the argument with a
structure like premise
1a is B premise 2a is C conclusion
therefore B is C it turns out that the
argument doesn't work apply this form to
a few cases and you'll figure out pretty
quickly that it fails arguments with a
working structure are valid arguments
that are broken get the negative label
invalid it would be premature of us to
stop there and declare that we have a
watertight argument we've checked our
structure but we haven't thought about
whether we filled our form with correct
statements the premises can be true or
false
and the conclusion true or false as a
result I could propose that all soups
are cold
anything that's cold can't burn your
mouth so clearly soups can't burn your
mouth the argument has a valid structure
but one of its supporting premises is
false which impacts the conclusion I'm
trying to draw if our argument is valid
and has true premises it's a sound
argument this may strike you as
straightforward but it's easy to get
lazy or manipulative with your logic and
end up producing or being convinced by
unsound arguments or should I say it's
easy for the other guy but not for so
logical mind as yours notice that either
truth or validity can impact the
soundness of an argument unsound
arguments include an invalid argument
with true premises a valid argument with
one or more untrue premises and an
invalid argument with untrue premises
only a valid argument with true premises
sound a tidbit you may be aware of but
our argument structure introduced above
a is B B is C so a is C is called a
syllogism so my coffee is food is a
valid syllogism with I will assert true
premises if that's all correct the
argument is sound not all arguments are
syllogisms notice that we have two
conditional premises if a then B if B
then C and the conclusion follows from
these conditions therefore if a then C
we could just use one conditional
premise like if a then B if we assert in
a second premise that a we conclude that
you guessed it B I haven't looked
outside these arguments to support them
I just relied on the structure and
persuasiveness of the premises to make
my point the meaning and words are all
there for you to
evaluate and if these are good then the
conclusions good - that's deductive
reasoning and the resulting argument is
called a deductive argument once I start
checking my facts outside my bare words
things get trickier if I want to support
my assertion that coffee is beans I have
to use inductive reasoning to look at
specific information in the real world
and make abstract generalizations about
all coffee even though I could never
hope to check if what I'm saying is true
even of a fraction of the world's coffee
such claims are probabilistic and open
until I can demonstrate that they are
false and arguments that take this line
of reasoning are inductive for instance
I can't demonstrate that my first
premise is true of all coffee ever but I
can state things that probably hold
which requires inductive reasoning you
might instinctively perform inductive
reasoning by checking against your own
experience but there are even more
methodical approaches
we called valid and true deductive
arguments sound when we come across
inductive arguments it's preferable to
talk about cogent see a cogent argument
is valid and has probable premises I've
thrown around the words true and truth
if you're like most of us you
intuitively feel you have some
understanding of what those words mean
the difference between deductive and
inductive thinking may have raised a few
issues but let's tackle the issue of
truth straight on digest each one of the
following questions and use them to get
a broad view on different perspectives
of truth in logic and philosophy is a
statement true when it aligns with is
consistent with and doesn't contradict
other true statements is a statement
true when it corresponds to something in
the real world can certain statements be
asserted as true in and of themselves
even self-evidently will truth then
deductively follow from these
assumptions is a statement true when it
proves to be useful or practical is a
statement true when enough people argue
or believe that it is true is truth not
an actual property of a statement at all
but something else can true or the truth
ever be predicated in a meaningful non
redundant way whatever your intuitions
what do you make of my coffee is a food
argument do you think it's sound in the
next video I'll share a perspective on
logical fallacies and take another look
at that argument